- And I'm so excited y'all are here.
But two years ago you
changed your band name.
And it took me a minute, y'all,
'cuz I was like, so used
to it from childhood.
- [Band Member] Yeah.
- But then I heard that this
was something that y'all
kind of had in the making
for a while, right?
- Yeah.
- What was so important to you
to change it to just The Chicks?
- Well, I think just after
George Floyd and all of that,
we'd wanted to get rid of
the Dixie part of our name
for a long time, but it seemed
like a huge thing to do.
So we would call, you know,
our merch would say DCX,
and we always referred to
ourselves as The Chicks.
So it seemed like a really natural change
and it seemed kind of seamless.
- Here's what was cool is you, like,
educated a lot of us as well
because I had no idea
that it meant anything.
So like I had to, like, Goo,
I was like, "Wait, what?"
And I was like Googling and it
was interesting to find out,
you know, kind of the origin of that word.
- Yeah, I did the same, I
always thought it was a region.
Like if it's what, what direction?
- South of the Mason-Dixon Line.
(laughing)
- Yeah. That's me too. So it was like,
it was interesting though.
I thought that that was,
that was a really cool to
educate the public, though,
on something, especially
at such an important time.
- [Natalie] Yeah.
- So I thought it was really
cool that y'all did that.
And also it's just, like, easier to say.
- (giggles)
- [Kelly] So that's awesome. I'm lazy.
- (laughs)
- But I love, and then I think everybody
would always say that, too,
"Oh, did you see The Chicks?
You see the concert?"
- Right
- Everybody would always call y'all that.
- Yeah.
- I think super fans like me.
So, what do you each remember
from like the very first time
that y'all played together?
Was it like awkward, or
like, you knew right away
it was gonna work.
- Well, Natalie had joined
the band, a previous lineup,
and so Marty and I were
very, like, nervous,
Like, "Will she, rehearse all the songs
and know all the songs?"
Natalie was just like, "Oh, I
got this, y'all, I got this."
- (laughing)
- [Emily] She had this confidence,
and Marty and I are just like,
"Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!"
But Natalie brought this humongous pad
with her lyrics on it,
(giggles)
and we just flip it in between songs.
- We played at these two
clubs in, outside of Houston.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I would just
(all laugh)
bend down, turn the page.
(laughing)
- Oh my God, do you have a
problem with lyrics? I do.
- No, but I had to learn
22 songs in seven days.
I would just listen with
headphones and walk around.
- And you did your yodel.
- Yeah, I had never yodeled before.
(laughing)
- That's a lot.
- [Natalie] I know.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
(laughing)
So the band was famously, I
had to be reminded of this,
The band was famously
boycotted on country radio
19 years ago, which feels
like forever ago to me.
But it happened after,
Natalie, you spoke out
against the war in Iraq and
the president in 2003, right?
So what did you, I ended up,
it was Shut Up And Sing, right?
The documentary that came out?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I loved that.
- (chuckles)
- I think a lot of
artists or anybody that's
under a microscope, I'm
jumping straight to that,
I'm gonna ask the question, but
I'm jumping straight to that
because when you're under a
microscope, everything you say,
even if you don't mean something
some way, or even if you,
it's in a moment, everything
gets blown up, good or bad.
And it's a very hard way to live.
And especially being in an industry,
like, I've been told to shut up and sing
and not have an opinion.
And it's very hard, 'cuz you're
a human and we all count,
you know, our thoughts
and our hearts count.
So how did y'all deal with that?
That had to be hard after
watching that, Shut Up And Sing,
that was hard, not only on y'all
but the people around you, right?
- Yeah, I don't know, I'm a fighter,
so I didn't, like, crumble,
(laughing)
I crumbled,
(audience applause)
- That's a Texas woman.
I did crumble, like, after
we won all the Grammys,
I kind of fell apart after that.
I think I was just,
like, in this fight mode,
and then it all sort
of came crashing down.
- Yeah. It's a lot of
weight to carry, yeah.
- Yeah. And it was for how it
was affecting other people,
I didn't care how it was affecting me.
- [Kelly] That's what I'm saying, like,
- But yeah.